first slice open a vanilla pod and
scrape out the seeds
now the flavor in those seeds is
mind-blowing okay beautiful now two
whole eggs in to give that a whisk next
add 125 grams of unsalted butter to the
mixer once the butter soft at 90 grams
of caster sugar and clean them together
until they're lovely and smooth
gradually pour in the beaten eggs and
vanilla seeds add a pinch of salt and
beat thoroughly until the mixture
becomes paler then put in 250 grams of
plain flour and mix until it forms a
dough just be nice and firm slightly
soft and not too wet perfect be careful
because you're holding your hands for
too long it starts to melt flour your
hands on the board and shape the dough
into a circle there's got a really nice
soft sensual sexy feel really nice and
creamy now roll it out to the thickness
of 1 centimeter cut out a large circle
then put it onto a baking tray lined
with parchment and decorate
half again just like my grandma's
tonight
thumb then and till the shortbread for
an hour to help it set then bake it a
medium oven for 20 minutes until it
turns a pale golden color just sprinkle
a little bit of sugar really nice to do
when it's just come out so it's sort of
it melts into the shortbread nice and
generous and that's perfect for a cup of
tea mid-afternoon as well as filling
your biscuit tin over Christmas the
shortbread can easily be transformed
into a great festive dessert using a hot
spoon scoop out lozenges of creme
fraiche and civil top then grate over
the zest of a Clementine
and finish with Clementine halves the
tartness of the creme fraiche works with
a sweetness of the Clementine
[Music]